es un hecho bastante conocido que para
calcular el área de un triángulo basta a
multiplicar su base por su altura y
dividir ese resultado entre dos por
ejemplo si aquí tengo un triángulo en el
cual sabemos que esta longitud es igual
a b y esta longitud es igual a h
entonces es muy conocido que el área del
triángulo el área es igual a un medio
multiplicado por la base multiplicado
por la altura por ejemplo si tuviera un
triángulo en el cual la base fuera
digamos 6 y la altura fuera 5 entonces
tendríamos que su área sería igual a un
medio de 5 bueno de 6 de 6 por 5 y eso
sería igual a un medio de 30 o sea 15 un
medio de 30 es decir 15 esto es algo muy
conocido lo que no es tan conocido es
cómo le podemos hacer para determinar el
área de un triángulo en el cual
únicamente conocemos sus lados
por ejemplo imagínate que tenemos un
triángulo así y sabemos que sus lados
miden y miden a b y c estas son las
longitudes de los lados del triángulo
como le podemos hacer para a partir de
esta información
determinar el área del triángulo bueno
pues lo que tenemos que hacer es aplicar
la fórmula de heron déjame escribir por
aquí fórmula de heron fórmula fórmula
fórmula de de perón perón y esto
básicamente es una fórmula que nos dice
cómo a partir de los lados de un
triángulo podemos determinar su área
ahorita no la vamos a demostrar porque
es un poco complicado en realidad si
tenemos todas las herramientas
básicamente se necesita el teorema de
pitágoras y un poco de álgebra
espeluznante pero bueno por el momento
únicamente te voy a decir qué dice la
fórmula deron y veremos cómo utilizarla
vale en realidad es una fórmula sencilla
y fácil de recordar es como sigue para
para escribir la fórmula a deron primero
vamos a calcular esta variable auxiliar
que es ese y ese lo voy a poner un poco
más para acá ese es simplemente la mitad
del perímetro es decir sumamos a b y c
aa + b más y lo dividimos entre 2 es el
semi perímetro y con esta variable
auxiliar ahora sí podemos escribir la
fórmula de heron la fórmula de heron
dice que el área del triángulo voy a
poner aquí el área
área del triángulo es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de la siguiente multiplicación
de s s esta variable que calculamos
arriba x s menos a x s v y x s menos c
donde a veces son justo las longitudes
entonces al al semi perímetro le
restamos cada uno de los lados
multiplicamos eso y también
multiplicamos por ese y sacamos raíz
vale entonces déjame meter aquí en un
cuadrado la fórmula de heron esta es la
fórmula la fórmula que nos interesa va
ok esta es la fórmula de heron ahora de
lejos puede parecer un poco intimidante
porque tiene una raíz y varias
multiplicaciones y definitivamente es
más intimidante que un medio de base por
altura verdad pero lo que ahorita vamos
a hacer es ver algunos ejemplos para ver
que en realidad no está tan mal y que si
es práctica vale bueno entonces digamos
déjame bajar para tener un poco de
espacio voy a dejar ahí la fórmula de
heron digamos que tenemos un triángulo
un triángulo lo voy a poner más o menos
así en el cual sabemos que sus lados
miden 9 9 11 y 16 entonces para aplicar
la fórmula de heron tendríamos que hacer
lo siguiente primero calculamos ese f
ese consiste en sumar 9 11 16 9 + 11 16
y dividir entre 2 eso de ahí es igual a
haber 9 + 11 es 20 más 16 36 entre 12 es
igual a 18 entonces ese es igual a 18 lo
que nos dice la fórmula deron es que
entonces el área
triángulo el área
a área es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 18 x 18 9 18
9 x 18 menos 11 menos 11 x 18 16 18
menos 16 sale y aquí podemos hacer las
cuentas esto de aquí es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 18 x 18 menos 99 18 menos 11
18 menos 11 7 y 18 16 que sería 2 x 2
bueno aquí ya puse unos paréntesis demás
y puse este muy largo déjame borrar lo
voy a borrar esta parte de acá bueno no
lo voy a dejar así porque si no creo que
se va a poner en blanco entonces eso de
ahí es igual vamos a hacerlo así 18 por
2 es igual a 36 entonces nos quedaría
como la raíz cuadrada de 36 x 9 x 7 y
esto lo podemos abrir como la raíz
cuadrada de 36 por la raíz cuadrada de 9
por la raíz cuadrada de 7 sale
simplemente abrí esta raíz en producto
la raíz de 36 6 la raíz de 9 estrés y
por lo tanto esto es igual a 18 raíz de
7 18 raíz de 7
de esta forma utilizando la fórmula de
aaron concluimos que el área de este
triángulo en esta área de acá
área es igual a 18 raíz raíz de 7 y en
realidad fue rápido nada más nos tomó un
par de minutos hay que encontrar esta
variable pero bueno como puedes ver no
es tan complicado utilizar la fórmula de
heron nos veremos en siguientes vídeos
para ver cómo se demuestra